abby ray has a long history in the
national league of course this will be
his
sixth time in his career he's pitched
against semester is jd davis the number
two hitter the third baseman for the
match hitting 271
and a swing and a miss at a fastball up
in the zone two down
right fielder michael conforto went two
for four with a home run last night
ray's got it stabbed it nicely on the
mound
and the side is retired in order you
know
seth lugo makes his fourth start for the
mets and he's fully stretched out now he
threw
81 pitches in his last outing that was a
week ago and a 5-1 win against the
phillies
well now bo buchet one-two pitch swung
on and missed strike three lugo going
away with a hard slider
and the shut down on strike saw two up
two down
so here is shaw on the 1-0 little
chopper pass them out
out towards short rosario's got it
throws to first in time and that retires
the side
so ray with a chance to get through this
inning two out of two on and jd davis
coming up
to shallow left field and a diving catch
made by goriel
ray loves it what a play by lourdes
goriel
jr i'll tell you buck i don't know what
you thought halfway through that play i
did not think he was going to catch that
no i didn't either but he never gives up
on these plays it's two outs and the
runners are moving on contact and here
comes lourdes
and he extends and he was able to hold
on to that baseball
seth lugo is on the mound in the bottom
of the third he has not allowed a base
runner yet
and beyond takes strike three called
fastball on the outside corner got him
looking
and lugo's got his third strikeout back
to the top of the order now with kevin
biggio
and they could hit good breaking ball so
lugo strikes out biggio with his
curveball that's his fourth strikeout of
the night
two out two on no score in the fourth
minute with a window of opportunity here
so now mariznick who would have come
back for his first time up
and mariznick swings at the first one
hits it over the bag and down the line
past the glove of shaw
that gets conforto in with the game's
first run canoe to third marisnick pulls
in at second with an rbi double
and the mets break in front one to
nothing boba shed is back after a
four week absence with the knee injury
and he's got himself a base hit welcome
back
we got that hanging breaking ball he
turns on it and rips it into left field
one to nothing mets second and third
nobody out
and a chopper up the third baseline this
will get the run home
and gritchix going to be safe at first
with an infield hit
a little squibber up the third baseline
and beau got a good break on it the
infidel was
back so he was able to break on contact
vlad junior the battle
and he chops one slowly luco's got this
but no recovering
he tries to get there and he does oh wow
seth lugo with the unassisted put out at
third base
he beat sean of the bag what presence of
mind by
lugo davis had vacated his position and
that was his only play
and now it'll be travis shaw with the
bases loaded in one down got to get
something out of this if you're the blue
jays
and shaw with a fly ball pretty well hit
to right center field
mariznick is going to make the catch
kirk will tag he'll come in to score
panic will go to third and the blue jays
have the lead
that's good if battle travis got the
ball out of the plane and all they want
to do is get it in the air to the
outfield and kurt comes in to score
after drawing the lead-off walk here in
the fifth
lefty chasing shreve comes on to relieve
seth lugo
rudder at third guerrero one out in
field in for the mets the blue jays
leading two to one bottom six and
jonathan vr now turns around to bat from
the right side
and sneaks one through the drawn in
infield
again the blue jays find a hole with a
ground ball and they lead three to one
the mets have runners on the corners one
out now and jd davis will be the banner
one two coming grounded to short a
chance for two
beshette had trouble getting out of his
glove and then it's dropped
on the exchange by panic and a run comes
home
well that was a taylormade double play
ball off the bat but bushette had
trouble
and then panic dropped it and so they
get just the one out as ramos scores
to cut the toronto lead to 3-2 miguel
castro
coming over from baltimore at the
trading deadline his fifth appearance
for the mets after
appearing in 16 games for the orioles
one two coming
and he struck him out with a change up
so castro has his first strikeout and
there's one down in the bottom of the
seventh
two and two of the pitch grechik swings
and misses strike three well this is as
filthy as we've seen miguel castro
since the mets got him from baltimore
3-2 from castro
and he struck him out with the slider so
castro strikes out the side in the
bottom of the seventh
right-hander rafael dolis comes on to
try to save this game for the blue chase
as we go to the ninth inning
if you can get a ground ball this is as
good a double play candidate as there is
in baseball
ground ball weakly hit to third to
second one
back to first they'll get him
how big was that this is ahmed rosario
he's the number nine hitter tonight but
he's three for three including a double
and he got it kirk's got to find the
ball though
and rosario is going to reach so it's
not over yet
and leadoff man jeff mcneal
and guerrero's pointing into the dugout
saying
have a look at this see if you want a
challenge and they are going to have a
look at it
he's out
picks off rosario to end the game